berlin wird an diesem samstag zur
protest hauptstadt rund 80 demos sind
angemeldet rund 20.000 menschen werden
erwartet
es ist eine lange liste gegen was da
alles demonstriert wird wir wollen uns
das mal genauer anschauen
das ende der pandemie tag der freiheit
heißt eine demonstration omas gegen
rechts der fahrradkorso alle macht den
echsen menschen nato abschaffen
staatenlos mahnwache vor dem reichstag
und werte unserer verfassung wo sind sie
geblieben so heißen einige der
versammlungen es wird also unter anderem
gegen die kur ohne einschränkungen aber
auch gegen rassismus auf die straße
gegangen wir haben uns in der hauptstadt
umgesehen ich möchte jetzt mit meinem
kollegen peter wilke sprechen
er ist in berlin vor ort peter wie ist
dort momentan die situation
[Applaus]
die situation hier ist momentan noch
relativ übersichtlich aber es kommen
immer mehr menschen in die nähe des
brandenburger tores stehen hier unter
den linden mitten in berlin bei der
demonstration des bündnisses von mona
leugnen
kritik an der groner maßnahmen quer
denken sie
1 aus stuttgart haben dazu aufgerufen zu
diesem protest hier und marschieren
jetzt werde durch die stadt in einem
großen bogen um dann schlussendlich an
der straße des 17 juni ganz der nähe des
reichstags zu enden und rufen hallt hier
dazu auf maßnahmen zu enden wie der
protest heißt sie für das ende der
pandemie aus was aber immerhin sich
darauf dass die infektionszahlen
mit grüner immer mehr steigen
deutschlandweit auf die in berlin
das dass es wirkt vielleicht allzu sehr
zu
peter wir sehen auch bei dir im
hintergrund sieht nicht so aus es würden
hier abstände gewahrt werden oder masken
getragen werden
wir haben denn die behörden das ganze im
griff und kümmern sich darum die
sicherheit der menschen
ja es ist ja noch ein relativ
überschaubar auftreten der polizei hier
ist intel an 1000 kräfte heute über ganz
berlin bei allen dänen im einsatz
die polizei sperrt hier nur die wege ab
für die demonstranten damit sie ohne
verkehrsbehinderungen durch die stadt
laufen können
ist aber alles ruhig und kein besonders
macht
wir haben eben ja die namen der demos
die alle angemeldet sind einmal
aufgelistet vielleicht kann sie uns mal
einen überblick geben wer versammelt
sich denn heute alles in der hauptstadt
und wohin geht es dieser demonstration
wir gegen die crawler maßnahmen sind
menschen aus ganz deutschland sogar
international aus der schweiz aus
österreich haben wir menschen gesehen
hergekommen die wohn mit bussen
hingefahren und versammeln sich dann
finden ans brandenburger tor und
ansonsten die größte andere prozess wird
eben der gegenprotest gegen diese leute
hier gegen die ziel in diesem protest
versammeln sich viele leute aus
verschiedensten durch
der störung
die 1
wir sprechen aber wir haben mehrere
menschen mit reichsbahn also
nationalisten
rechtsextremisten
impfgegner also dass es wie ein unter
mixen und ansonsten haben wir schon
gehört kommt wird auch viel gegen
rassismus mit den gegen rechts und
anderen demonstrationen protestiert die
finden aber nicht hier statt sondern
mehr in teilen deutschland mit gerade
gesamtplatz
weiterhin